guardando tutti ragazzi e benvenuti sim
e questo il monito di minecraft parkour
è un film con pietro bisogno due gol che
se cacchio da vedendo io posso fare con
il mezzo che quello che vi si schifa
della vita ci vedeste di veder te devi
fare dobbiamo fare
marconi che non era vedo bene vai ok
bravissimo ok ok marche va bene mamma mi
hanno fatti cioè è finito ma no cazzata
e allora
oddio no non è finito una sega che è
provata mammamia proprio lui palaspes
nudity aspettative che devo capire nov
aveva in difficilissimo capire cosa devi
fare qua qua no a non si sveli devi
salire secondo e amiche saline dove
cacchio salgo è perché devo salire devo
fare il giro quindi qualche modo per la
scienza è per la scienza google proprio
per la scienza stati no non ci posso
andare sulla la fa sul tardi che è
morbido buttafuori saranno scivolata
forse il lato aspetto quello slam sul
club per fare qualcosa di sì no no no no
no per favore che veramente cioè voglio
fare un gioco
no per favore l'onda baiano non sento
soltanto 80 miglia mia ti voglio vedere
mai allora calare come l'angelo
dall'angolo all'ump no all'angolo ma
sono mai all'angolo [ __ ]
o bravi mente stessa aspetta fretta
spettano o mamma mia
ho rischiato fidati non l'hai visto
hanno rischiato come come ci arrivo
sulla lampada è vai dritto dritto e poi
meglio prima di 350 fare nice nice
bravo ok bravo criminale c'era il caso
sotto se non avrei fatto o no
meno male nella sola capace di conviene
attesa dai marchi maggio niente tutti
facili e tecniche dobbiamo capire
veramente che sono più ma da qua che
cacchio dobbiamo fare andare sulla
catena o no è un momento in cui non sia
persone non penso mentre ribadiscono
bravissimo ma si fa così almeno dimmelo
non lo so penso di sì pensate potuto
direttamente di funziona ciao amico è
stato bellissimo
ah che bello allora la partenza non è
male è molto carina ciao mikè vieni di
alan g min seconda meta dritto dritto
sullo slime ma questo è un livello
bellissimo questo è lo dirai tra un po
perché il società di capire come quando
e perché sbatti la testa o no subito tra
due è facilissimo quello amico dai
sbatto la testa come devo fare così ma
porca vacca devo andare sullo slide
bisogna dare sull'altro slime perché
l'ha sbattuto la testa è un bordello ma
riguardanti pato per sbattere tra scusa
mi va bene sarai diritto sbatte la testa
esalti infatti la testa e un muro c'è un
muro invisibile corniola più atteso è
quello e non so all'altro sliven forse
di andare allora sì sì sì sì è giusto
giusto difficilissimo però
uno slancio pazzesco presidente giusto
dare all'altro offline ok mi devi fare
un giro pazzesco ma cio che si faceva
secondarie cioè più o meno non è non è
non è facile però perché bella bella
bella tosta qua va dove vado a renderla
ecco fatto arrivare lì cosa poi fatto
arriva alla studio come è cioè come
feste come stato fortissimo questo giro
massa ma come come possibile ma come hai
fatto
ma spetta come hai fatto a passare di là
è ricaduto con me ma non ho capito come
hai fatto ad arrivare lassù senza fare
questa cosa
adesso nella dc l'ho fatta quella
cantone ma non l'hai fatta non so più se
lo facciano in avanti e non era un
ragazzino dalla ero davanti non è
possibile andare andare nell'angolo
angolo sotto la scala in questo esatto
io vi giuro che non ho capito ve lo
giuro che uno fortissimo non eri davanti
a me come cachi fatto a fare quel salto
pietro sporca ma cosa spacchi bravissima
unico che arrivò che con tipo ravissimo
devo pensare che il secondo me mela
condom e la continuità aspetta che la
scusami ma questo vuol dire una diffida
è stata benissimo ora qui sopra mai
ora la scaletta allora allora allora
fammi capire cos'è qua ma tu l'hai
schermatura la vela anche schiacciato
questo sarebbe schiacciare cioè amiche
io ti aspetto del problema ma va bene
sembra assurda sta roba va bene
all'accettazione voce nella ho capito ho
capito dico guarda non è vero c'è un
blocco è visibile niente per la geofarma
insieme ha capito le cose e il tutto
sbagliato una volta da una verifica di
matematica tutta completa 10 ha preso
due ma te lo giuro che solamente ma ero
convinto
ok ma che comunque ma senza corda marco
incavolata quindi sotto che mi soffermi
fa va a cagare
vai dritto è così è facile nice
sì io questo intendevano
ma più o meno non era facile lo stesso
madonna di dio
no non era per ce la meritiamo ce lo
meritiamo ce lo meritiamo ce lo
meritiamo
ce lo siamo meritati ce lo siamo
meritati io sono una brava persona i
numeri è un po un po cosa un po un po un
po caldo ma quasi girare coronata ma e
ronco in tronco eccoci eccoci dove da
qualche faccio e non lo sono il suo nome
la parola sopra ok ok che bordello non
si capisce niente
no vabbè fermi
non so se mi conviene farlo la pro
dall'acqua avevo già qua perfetto mi
conveniva parla tua età qua teoricamente
madonna ho rischiato tantissimo ce l'ho
fatta e poi ce lo fa o fili no aspetta a
siligo teoricamente al mese appello
aspetta aspetta che funzionano per i
nomi che non mi spingere che già è
difficile devi andare devi anche dove
cacchio fa che cosa fai
stai fermo madonna vai sul pianale tu io
sì però da quando da quando di scendere
18 non è di moda quali va madonna faccio
io no non è restato fermo detto mica
faccio io
non è forse non l'hai fatto le cose non
l'hai fatto non l'hai fatto tutto fatto
sì ho fatto cioè avuto un pulsante
io veramente la mia
guarda io io nella mia vita poche volte
dovuto tenere pazienza così da questa è
una di quelle questa è una di quelle con
questo gioco pietro un bordello perché
mi spinge farò be ma ci manca solo cosa
devo fare qua e non è anche guardato
perché vi sono trigger ato per prima
cosa devo fare poi un lato positivo
amiche linz calzatura che hai per me che
ha permesso di non arrabbiarti per il
fatto che ci sia il ghiaccio in questo
livello è vero non ho neanche notato hai
visto beh ma tanto non sto capendo
questo dobbiamo fare da quaquaraqua su
ok qua qua qua amico da qua qua sopra al
comune e devi devi farlo ebbe mai facile
barba esatto vai vai e deve essere mai
la sua perfetto e fa il giro poi quale
immagina qua dai vari paesi indicazioni
precise esatto amico però divide
riuscire più dovuto dire vero ok casa
facce della roba anaci nell'acqua devo
andare veloce se non muoio ama dei
crociati con control e poi e poi senza
risalita di tornare ma non c'è più ok ma
bordello ben fatto ah ok o chiamare da
un perfetto si si si non asi ciò che ho
fatto un pò cioè non era facile per
niente ma va però il solo già prendiamo
un altri per cui sopra bene va bene ma
mi sono fatto no era bevilacqua marine
level comunque era bella guardo stop ho
finito titoli
forse si no cosa è finito perché può
andare la quale prossimo non ci credo
sto male
definiamo il primo tiro ho sentito che
ti sistemo le ginocchia contributo per
falco ma come faccio no non ci arrivano
non si può dai su sì uomo ma non si può
fare e come farlo sto pensando di casa
che figo tipo al posto di sì un uomo si
un'ape beb questa cava
no ragazzi che prova a fare quello se ci
riescono sempre a fare cose coraggio
browser ma perché non ti fai cavoli tuoi
mi metti a non si situa la guardia
americana ci credo non ci posso credere
non ci posso credere in un tentativo
signori signori che a player che player
madonna ce l'ho fatto tutto incredibile
in un tentativo pazze
dobbiamo entrare il card da che parte
però è che ne so io ci entrò poi dove
voi no ahia ahia porca ayane
apache della roma ok devi venire qua ser
incastrati card no aspetta sotto la neve
chi cazzo di carta hai preso e mi sto
per lo sviluppo di cava aiutata bene
basti a matt andata anche bene che ti
sei tolto tanto ragazzi non ho capito
assolutamente cosa devo fare qua ma non
è che non si trova di carte io che siamo
a 2 40 carte prima infatti c'è non si
capisce più niente certo punto secondo
me vanno avanti così non riuscivamo a
fare niente e poi perché non riceviamo
davanti ma come si sa bene quando va
bene ok e poi l'acqua ti fai tutto il
tour che non so fare capito benissimo
non chi non so farlo guarda che bravo
che sono bravo madonna che casino
skicard di odio non ci sono più solo
soffre carte stanno correndo perché per
i nervi e il lancio di correre sono più
che fastidio un audio madonna ok
problemi va bene poi delle semi che non
ho capito è che su questo proprio da me
ok è vero che carpi e parlava fini devi
fare questo cosa da fare qua di risalire
sulla staccionata guarda saliti sopra
esatto bravissimo poi mi puoi dire qual
è il problema che non so chi c'è penso
di far saltare occhio però perché qua
non fare cagate aspetta
no no già controllato in questa è
l'unica via possibile io ti voglio ti
voglio bene
guardami così bene bravo che andrò
anch'io però avrei buttato la stessa
dove erano amiche ho capito ho capito
che è un attimo punto di più
vai agli apporti che fai
ok se ti trasporta gli altri in mano
allora il mattino stavo capendo ceca
goup ok quindi praticamente bisogna fare
dice sì sì perché se cadi torni su ok
del set quindi devi andare le 100 per
100 100 100 nice
la faccio corretta perché siculo vedere
questi avranno previsto cose non mi cada
ismo e di farlo no milano proprio ad
altro oltre bravo è visto solo
addirittura prima sono per la rarissima
bravi grafici e non so come cacchio fate
che non so cosa ci dice una scala
non è questa non è una figata comunque
molto si molto bello dopo bene i
consigli a volte però mi che no no no
non ha idea non ha idea fidati che non
ha idea non è la guardia non vorresti
vedere quello che sto vedendo io però
non quando arriverai qua lo vedrai
purtroppo piquet daeke dormendo e una
pausa
guardami che guarda avanti
erano così belle le porte torniamo a
giocare con le forze per favore non
aveva neanche un male non ci hanno
ancora provato l'avevo detto possiamo
rompere il gioco guardai vedevano
schiaccia stato bravissimo ha fatto bene
sbagliata quando sai che in realtà è
infatti secondo me non è difficile ma
non guardi non è difficile
ok e poi e poi non lo so ma io sono ora
spetta non è che devi fare qua detto ma
tu puoi passare in mezzo a sto coso sono
stai parlando mi
caput ansa no no allora no vado dritto
ma che ansia vede i pistoni che si leva
da sotto i piedi ma infatti c'è un
casino ok a un altra roba di fi storico
aspetta o no se scherzando ma chissà che
abbiamo sbagliato
allora smetto ok ma no non lo abbiamo
sbagliato perché dobbiamo passare sopra
sopra sti cosi non sono credente per cui
farcela bravissimo ancora dal brasile di
ansia tre bogey è facile poi questo è
facile amico cori che vi sono bloccati
in mezzo in vestali come come cosa cosa
vuol dire aspetta aspetta aspetta di
adattamento liberati variava da aia
grazie ma che vivono tra abbiamo pieni i
ragazzi questo era il video di marcature
di oggi spero mi sia piaciuto continuavo
nel terzo episodio e come sempre
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un bel
commento vi piace qui sotto che li leggo
e noi come sempre cedere prossimo video
[Musica]